so when I grew up I used to watch a TV
series called the food hospital the aim
of the show was to use diet as a
mechanism to treat a variety of
different diseases and so the patients
in Missouri has had a range of
conditions ranging from common problems
like chronic fatigue and femur and the
more unusual such as fish odor syndrome
occult to life-threatening diseases like
type 2 diabetes and breast cancer these
patients came to the food hospital when
their diet would be changed I know we
looked at to see if any of their
symptoms would be improved manipulating
the composition of diets resonates with
what Hippocrates said let food be thy
medicine but besides just changing the
composition of diet what is currently
being water's felt is the revolutionary
idea that when we eat is equally if not
more important than what we eat so hello
and welcome to the Shiki science show
where I thought it was about time to
talk about time in eating so this video
will be your comprehensive guide to what
is intimate and fasting and the
different types of intermittent fasting
then we'll talk about what actually
happens during this fasting periods and
then we look at studies that attuned to
positive impacts and how intermittent
fasting improves glucose regulation
stress resistance and suppresses
information and how that has beneficial
impacts for a variety of different
diseases will then talk about some of
the problems of intermittent fasting and
some words of warning and a discussion
of how it differs to our cultural norms
and lastly we'll talk about sort of an
outlook and just a summary of why when
you eat is so important to consider but
before we go any further I'm just going
to put the disclaimers out the way but
first as a youtuber I realized that what
I say can resonate and impact your own
opinions and you may emphasis on the may
look to me for words of wisdom and
advice
whilst I am truly flattered science is
science because it is experimental not
precise and we are all individuals
living our individual lives and there
may be reasons why interested fasting
may be unsafe or unwise fee and so I'm
really throwing my thoughts and opinions
here in this video so please do your own
research first and consult doctors
before you consider doing anything such
as intermittent fasting so let's get on
with the video
whilst the properties may be famous for
saying let food be thy medicine
Benjamin Franklin is famous for saying
to lengthen thy life lessened by Mills
so there are two ways that you can
interpret the statement one is a
reduction in the total amount of food in
eaten or the other one which is just
reducing the number of times that one
actually eats during a day so the format
would be calorie restriction which is
the chronic reduction of total calorie
intake without malnutrition whereas the
latter is intermittent fasting is
strategy for meal timing scheduling
there are variety of different ways that
one can intermittent fast and so this
includes time restricted feeding by a
daily meal consumption is restrained to
a full two 12-hour window without
calorie restriction other alternative
methods such as alternate day fasting
where you eat one day in Fast & X to
periodic fasting and fasting limiting
diets so these methods resonates with
what Benjamin Franklin believed that the
best of all medicines is resting and
fasting so whilst Benjamin Franklin said
this in the 1700s it wouldn't be until
the 1930s and up to the present date
that we start to get some evidence that
seems to support his theory but before
we get on to the evidence
what is the chemistry and biochemistry
behind intermittent fasting what
actually happens to the body during a
fast well firstly we need to consider
the two main sources of energy for cells
this is glucose and fatty acids
after eating glucose is used for energy
and fat as thought and adipose tissue
has triglycerides excess glucose gets
thought in the liver as glycogen all of
the help of insulin is converted into
these fatty acids and so pleated to
other parts of the body and stored as
fat in adipose tissue during fasting
where energy is restricted for 10 to 14
hours there is a depletion in the liver
glycogen stores and hydrolysis of these
triglycerides into free fatty acids
these free fatty acids are then secreted
from the adipose tissue and make their
way to the liver where they're converted
into ketone bodies these ketone bodies
can be used by the cells as an energy
source
so effectively during fasting you have a
metabolic switch from liver derived
glucose to a Depot cell drives
ketone body
one of the implications of this changes
is a reduction in the respiratory
exchange ratio and so this is the ratio
of carbon dioxide produced to oxygen
consumption and this indicates the grace
of metabolic flexibility and efficiency
of energy production from fatty acids
and ketone bodies so fasting shouldn't
be thought of as a glucose surprised
States but as a normal ketone rich state
that serves as own important functions
so the concentration of these ketone
bodies actually fluctuates throughout a
day from around 100 to 250 micrometer
and these levels can rise to around 1
millimolar after a prolonged exercise or
24 hours of fasting but it's important
to point out that you don't want to
reach around 20 millimeter
concentrations which is the level seen
in pathological states like diabetic
ketoacidosis but besides being used as
fuel for the cells what else are these
ketone bodies doing well it turns out
that there are several indirect effects
of the ketone bodies in addition to its
function as fuel and these indirect
effects arise because the generation of
ketone bodies alters the ratio of
different metabolites such as coenzyme a
to acetyl coenzyme a nad plus 2 the
reduced form NADH and the ratio of a MP
to the energy source ATP now these
different metabolites have a variety of
different functions within a cell but
one of them involves the modification of
marks on DNA known as epigenetic marks
and this can also gene expression
patterns and so the genes that are
altered and then expressed in a fasted
state compared to a Fed state can have
different impacts for the cell so let's
take a look at some of these changes so
I'm gonna draw a diagram that shows how
intimate and fasting impacts on some
nutrient signaling pathways and their
downstream consequences and so I've
mentioned that the intimus in fasting
alters the ratio of NADH to increase the
levels of nad plus
energy loss is a key metabolites
required by certain enzymes such as
sirtuins and statins CST laid different
proteins and these proteins includes
foxy proteins PG C 1 alpha and RF 2 the
activation of these proteins results in
the expression of genes important stress
resistance and mitochondrial biogenesis
and ultimately risk results in cell
survival and so collectively what we see
during incident fasting within a cell is
the minimization of anabolic processes
which is the synthesis grate and
reproduction pathways and and instead we
see the favoring of pathways involved in
maintenance and repair systems which
enhanced stress resistance and recycled
damaged molecules and stimulates
mitochondrial biogenesis to help promote
cell survival and this can always have
important improvements in health and
disease in addition one of these ketone
bodies beta hydroxy butyrate has been
shown to promote synaptic plasticity and
neurogenesis by increasing the
expression of the neurotrophins brain
derived neurotrophic factor BDNF and CBD
NF helps to support survival of neurons
and also encourages the new growth and
differentiation of neurons and synapses
so intimate and fasting results in the
reduced signaling 3 proteins such as
mTOR and an increase in the processes
that activate Auto Fujii a cellular
recycling process that removes
dysfunctional proteins
aggregates and organelles through self
digestion which helps to promote
cellular integrity and function
so we've now looked at the biochemical
consequences for fasting but what are
the actual prolonged
outcomes of this in terms of different
clinical diseases well if we go back to
history that came out in the 1930s it
showed that by reducing the calorific
intake or frats it expended their lives
and it's important to realize that not
only were they calorie restricting these
mice the methods that the
to give the rats to feed also meant that
they were implementing intermittent
fasting whereby the rats actually had a
daily fasting period of up to 20 hours
and I'll since then we've are better
understood the differences and
importance of calorie restriction
compared to intermittent fasting we now
have much more studies that have shown
more directly the impacts of
intermittent fasting compared to just
calorie restriction and more and from
that other studies have gone on from
just looking at lifespan to looking at
specific diseases instead initially
there were health benefits of
intermittent fasting were present tons
of weight loss and reduced free radical
production but from then we now have a
fuller understanding of the consequences
and they extend to include improved
glucose regulation increased stress
resistance and suppression of
inflammation which are mediated through
these different nutrients signaling and
additional pathways within a cell that
we've already spoken about due to this
metabolic switch so a lot of the results
that come from these studies have been
conducted in mortal organisms such as
mice and rats whether there have been a
few studies that have been done in
humans that involved short-term trials
of intermittent fasting that was because
the aim of these current Charles was
more to the idea of the safety and
tolerance of humans to intermittent
fasting before it's taken to clinical
studies and further looked at so for
example a recent study that came out in
September 2019 alternate day fasting
improves physiological and molecular
markers of Aging and healthy non obese
humans showed that in these healthy
non-abs humans alternate day fasting was
safe to practice for several months and
within this period of fasting they saw
reductions in body weights by 4.5% and
improvements in the fat to lean ratio
also they saw improvements in the risk
for cardiovascular disease in another
study overweight women were assigned to
either a five to two intermittent
fasting regimen where they eat normally
for five days and fast for two days or a
25% reduction in
caloric intake the women and the two
groups lost the same amount of weights
during the six-month period but there
isn't a group as designed to divide to
intermittent fasting had a greater
increase in insulin sensitivity and a
larger reduction in waist circumference
besides studies looking at the
relationship between intimate and
fasting and cardiovascular disease has
been some more recent exciting studies
looking at the connection between
intermittent fasting and cancelled fed
mint and neurodegenerative disorders
with regards to cancer the studies seem
to show a two pronged positive effect in
terms of one reducing the growth of
tumors and two increasing the
sensitivity to chemotherapy and
radiation so improving the efficacy of
these treatments for example a 2009
study showed that in cancer patients a
five to fifty six hour duration or
fasting prior to and/or after
chemotherapy was well tolerated and
reduce side effects of chemotherapy
which was consistent with previously
discussed results that have been seen in
yeast mice ants mammalian cells and so
one of the hypotheses for why we have
this benefit is due to the fact that as
we've mentioned intermittent fasting
promotes this metabolic switch and this
adaptive process for the cells to be
able to respond to reduce nutrition and
cancer cells that have become like
dysfunctional are unable to adopt their
stress resistant state and therefore not
protected or sensitized to stress but
whilst the actual biochemical
underpinnings regarding these responses
is still far from clear it's exciting to
know that there are ongoing trials to
focus on Intimus in fasting in patients
with breast ovarian prostate
endometrial and Carol rectal cancers as
well as glioblastoma it's also worth
mentioning that the interest and
excitement for intermittent fasting as
opposed to calorie restriction with
regard to the cancer treatment is
favourable because a lot of patients
live cancer how something referred to as
cachexia which is characterized by
weight loss and so having calorie
restriction could potentially have more
severe consequences
answers so what about neurodegenerative
disorders now there isn't very
interesting hypothesis perspective
articles but the reality is at moments
there isn't that much data from
controlled trials and intermittent
fasting and persons at risk for or
affected by a neurodegenerative disorder
such as Alzheimer's disease or
Parkinson's disease but it's important
to note that these neurodegenerative
disorders are very much age associated
disorders and given that that is more
data especially in mice and rat models
that show you the benefits of
intermittent fasting and extending house
Battin well more so lifespan then there
does seem to be some potential link
between they're also having an
improvement in preventing
neurodegenerative disorders another
problem is that we don't fully
understand the major causes and driving
these neurodegenerative disorders in the
first place at the moment however one
that kind of hypothesis that seems to be
getting more support for is the role of
inflammation in driving these disorders
and so given that intermittent fasting
seems to be preventing the expression of
information and information is also been
associated with obesity and cancer and
we've seen data sharing that because the
beneficial impacts of intermittent
fasting it also kind of suggests that
they should all done with the also a
benefit of intermittent fasting or
neurodegenerative diseases as well I
think it's just too early to say for
certain so the evidence supporting
intermittent fasting each year just
keeps on increasing so are there any
problems with intermittent fasting well
although I already kind of speak about
its jus my disclaimer obviously there
could be personal individualized reasons
for where it might be a bad idea and
this is partly related to the fact that
these studies they haven't fully
considered different genders different
diets different ages and also genetic
factors that might implicate and either
enhance or synergize with intermittent
fasting but it's just very unclear at
the moment
for example especially considering young
adults or children and might be more
risky because they're so developing and
in particular pregnancies I have no idea
what the consequences of intermittent
fasting would be during a pregnancy but
besides these individual problems there
are also practical considerations which
are preventing the widespread adoption
of these eating patterns in the
community and my patients so you I split
the land to three kind of major
considerations the first one is the fact
is such a big lifestyle change it's so
ingrained in our culture to have a diet
or three meals you know breakfast lunch
and dinner with snacks in between you
know and it's very hard to go against
that ingrained pattern that we just used
to and told us the ideal way for us to
live and to kind of rephrase from this
article what would be the actual chances
that be absolutely nailed it with
regards to having the healthy normal
living style pattern sorted out you know
it would be unlikely that we would just
find it straight away but more on from
this it extends further to you all of
the advertisement and industries that
thrive on us you know fulfilling this
the Remillard a pattern and that as well
would be an impediment to you having
more people doing this and also there's
also kind of practical considerations in
terms of how it would fit into your own
routine depending on your work shift if
you've got a family to support
it just isn't practical for everyone and
I mean that's true but there's also ways
that you could go around it because
there are multiple different ways of
doing intermittent fasting so that's
practical consideration one the second
consideration is that adopting to an
intermittent fasting pattern regardless
of which one it is takes time and a lot
of effort because initially many people
will experience hunger irritability and
a reduced ability to concentrate during
periods of food restriction
however own Germany D side effects will
go after one month as your body adapts
and gets used to this routine it's just
currently has been so you programmed to
follow in a more consistent continued
eating they're just
when you're hungry and then thirdly most
physicians are not trained to prescribe
such regimens that our patients at the
moment and so this would require changes
within the teaching of practitioners so
that they can fully understand what
intermittent fasting is and the benefits
but I guess as well this would be
implemented once there is more research
backing the data supporting the health
benefits of intermittent fasting but if
any patients were to go on it they would
also require continued communication and
support from their physicians and
require positive reinforcement to
continue with the schedule because as I
said initially it could take up to a
month to get used to it and I think I
vaguely touched on this already but my
point is that intermittent fasting is
very much just eating the same as you
normally words in terms of content it's
just giving us at specific times and so
if these benefits that we see in our
tree it could reduce so much money and
strain on healthcare services because it
can help prevent so many different
diseases but the point is is that's also
now for loss of profits from companies
that I've developing drugs companies
that are you know having restaurants
having for you 24/7 and if there's no
profit to be made why would they get
permitted I mean I'm interested to hear
other people's views on this topic
because I think it's interesting and
definitely getting more widespread
adoption so what do I think is the
future outlook for intermittent fasting
well firstly I think those does need to
be a lot more clinical studies and
investigations particularly into the
biochemical underpinnings regarding the
impacts all fasting on cells and their
billing pathways and this should also be
looked at with regards to different ages
and genders and moreover different
genetic factors and so I do think that
in the future there could be some kind
of personalized nutrition program that
we could either choose to follow or not
follow I mean I think it would take a
lot of power and machine learning to
kind of engrave all that different
information to give you some kind of
outcome but I
do you think that kind of as well
beheading the other thing I think is
potentially going to be changing is
obviously we've mentioned the practical
considerations we're trying to follow in
tourism fasting and how challenging
actually can be and so alternative
strategies are to have intermittent
fasting loonatics so different
supplements that can be taken to achieve
the same impact without having to do the
intermittent fasting so these could
include such as NAD+ precursors which I
spoken about in previous videos and but
you know one line of thought is that
they would never be quite as effective
as doing the intermittent fasting in the
first place
another area of untapped research
potential with regards to intermittent
fasting is the influence of the diet on
the microbiome and how the composition
the microbiome and the timing can also
influence these different disease states
and so hopefully I'll continue that up
in a future video so hopefully you've
learned something from was quite
intensive discussion about intermittent
fasting I've had fun hope you have
you've had fun and thanks for listening